so tonight's I will be speaking at
Baylor University as I'm sure you've
heard by now and here in Waco Texas as
part of the young America's Foundation
campus tour if you can't make it out you
can catch the livestream on YouTube at
yaf TV so tune in and share share share
share I have I have to say flying into
Dallas last night was a little rough it
was a very bumpy flight and I'm an
extremely nervous flier I fly all the
time but it doesn't get any better so I
was I would just to give you an idea of
how how bad my paranoia is in the middle
of the of the flight well while the
turbulence was really bad I was
frantically trying to get connected to
Wi-Fi so that I would be able to to text
my wife goodbye in case the plane
started going down that's where my
that's where my head was
and then the other thought this is even
more sad the even sadder the other
thought that I had after I thought about
my family my second thought was that if
this plane goes down some of the
protesters at Baylor are going to be way
too happy about that and I started
thinking of all the snarky tweets they
would send about the fact that I died in
a plane crash and so I just started
praying to God like please Lord don't
give them that satisfaction just just
please so essentially I was praying for
the plane not to crash out of spite
that's why that's what it was and my
prayers worked because I am I'm here to
get here today so all right a lot to
talk about today and we'll get we'll get
into all of that but first I have to say
one of the one other thing here at the
top we're never going to agree on
everything right but I think we can all
agree that we could all use some more
sleep and I say that as somebody who got
probably three hours of sleep last night
but my rough night would have been a lot
easier if this hotel that I'm staying in
had the world's softest sheets from
Boland branch everything Boleyn branch
makes from bedding to blankets is made
from pure 100% organic cotton we all
care about we want things to be organic
these days
you want your cotton to be organic which
means they start out supersoft and they
get even softer over time imagine if
like a unicorn stitched you a set of
sheets out of a cloud and bunny rabbit
fur and and that's basically what these
sheets are like okay everyone who tries
Boleyn branch sheets loves them that's
why they have thousands of five-star
reviews you can go check it out
Forbes The Wall Street Journal and Fast
Company are all talking about Boleyn
branch also by the way if you use these
sheets you will be using sheets that
three u.s. presidents have also enjoyed
not the same exact sheets
okay just but the point is that they
also were Boleyn branch fans Boleyn
branch wants you to love your purchase
too so they offer a no risk 30-day trial
and free shipping but you're not gonna
want to send them back that's money
that's my that's my guess once you sleep
on their sheets you're not gonna want to
sleep on anything else so to get you
started right now
my listeners get $50 off your first set
of sheets you get 50 bucks off at Boleyn
branch dot-com promo code met go to
Boleyn branch calm today for $50 off
your first set of sheets that's bull Bo
ll and branch calm promo code met Boleyn
branch calm promo code Matt don't have
another rough night like I had last
night
get Boleyn branch alright let's talk
about a person that I have avoided
discussing on this show mainly because I
don't want to have to deal with
pronouncing this person's name and and
so this will be the first time that I
pronounce it because up until now I've
only written it this is my debut
pronunciation very exciting stuff you
all get to be here for this okay Pete
Buddha gig booting boo dead judge who
dig buddhic boot edging boot egg boot a
judge no I already said that boot a gag
boo-boo to judge Buddha Jenner I think
that's it Buddha judge Buddha JetBlue to
judge sounds like I'm summoning some
sort of dark
from the from the underworld Buddha
judge anyway well maybe we'll just call
him Pete from now from here on out he's
one of the one of the sort of long shot
Democrat candidates 38 year old mayor of
South Bend Indiana getting a lot of
attention because of his youth but also
because he does have an impressive and
interesting resume he's a Rhodes Scholar
combat veteran clearly a very
intelligent person well-spoken
formidable candidate I think and in a
crowd that includes some candidates who
are over 300 years old
I think his youth is also a big plus for
him mayor Pete is also openly gay and
this is a fact that has come to the
foreground in recent days has come to
the foreground because he has put it in
the foreground a couple of days ago
while giving a speech to a gay rights
group he had this to say watch this
people talk about things like marriage
equality as a moral issue and it is
certainly a moral issue as far as I'm
concerned it's a moral issue because
being married to chasten has made me a
better human being because it has made
me more compassionate more understanding
more self-aware and more decent my
marriage to chasten has made me a better
man and yes mr. vice president it has
moved me closer to God you may be
religious and you may not but if you are
and you were also queer and you have
come through the other side of a period
of wishing that you weren't then you
know that that message that this idea
that there is something wrong with you
is a message that puts you at war not
only with yourself but with your maker
and speaking only for myself I can tell
you that if me being gay was a choice it
was a choice that was made far far above
my paygrade
[Applause]
and that's the thing I wish the Mike
Pence's of the world would understand if
you got a problem with Who I am
your problem is not with me your quarrel
sir is with my Creator so he's decided
for some reason to go after Mike Pence
and this isn't the first time that he's
talked about Mike Pence um he's been
talking about Mike Pence a lot over the
last few days keep in mind that mayor
Pete is the mayor is a mayor in Indiana
pence used to be governor of Indiana so
you think okay well maybe pence
mistreated Budaj Pete somehow while they
were in Indiana and maybe that's why
Pete has something against him well
actually interestingly enough we do have
a clip of Mike Pence talking about mayor
Pete back in 2015 when he was governor
and Pete was mayor and so here's what
pence had to say about him
well I I hold a mayor bootie judging the
highest personal regard and we have a
great working relationship
I see him as a it's a dedicated public
servant and a patron that unbelievable
bigot I mean how could he say that oh
wait a second he's no he just said that
Pete's a great guy and and a patriot he
could not have been more glowing in his
appraisal but the interesting thing
about mayor Pete is that while he's
openly gay very liberal in many respects
as well he talks a lot about faith and
is sort of inculcating this image of
being a devout Christian as you saw in
that clip as he's talking about God his
creator and so on and he not only talks
about faith but he uses it against his
opponents watch this from Meet the Press
a couple of days ago you said some
rather strong about the president that
you said it's hard to look at his
actions and believe that they are the
actions of somebody who believes in God
how do you square that assessment with
the fact that the evangelical Christian
community is so devoted to his candidacy
well it's it's something that really
frustrates me because the hypocrisy is
unbelievable here you have somebody who
not only acts in a way that is not
consistent with anything that I hear in
Scripture in church where it's about
lifting up the least among us and taking
care of strangers which is another word
for immigrants and making sure that
you're focusing your effort on the poor
but also personally how you're supposed
to conduct yourself not chest-thumping
look at me ISM but humbling yourself
before others of foot-washing is one of
the central images in the New Testament
and we see the diametric opposite of
that in this presidency I think there
was perhaps a cynical process where he
decided to for example begin to pretend
to be pro-life and govern accordingly
which was good enough to bring many
evangelicals over to his side but even
on the version of Christianity that you
hear from the religious right which is
about sexual ethics I can't believe that
somebody who is caught writing
hush-money checks to adult film
actresses is somebody they should be
lifting up as the kind of person you
want to be leading this nation now all
things being equal I agree with with
some of what he what he just said right
there it's true that Trump's behavior
often not at all consistent with the
gospel or Christian ethics they're
simply no denying that
and it's true that Trump has as we know
a certain base of obsessive supporters
who basically worship him like a god and
if humiliated themselves in their faith
by actively excusing some church some of
trumps worst conduct including paying
off porn stars who he had affairs with
while his wife was at home with her
infant son so he's not he's not wrong
about some of that but but speaking of
unbelievable hypocrisy mayor peep
demonstrates it himself because here he
is or he was just there talking about
about faith bringing faith into it and
he does this a lot
talking about the gospel and Jesus the
creator everything but then then watch
what happens this is interesting so he's
talking about faith everywhere watch
what happens though when he's asked
about late-term abortion do you do you
support the late term abortion
legislation that was passed in the New
York State Legislature as well as in
Virginia I don't think we need more
restrictions right now and you know what
I've learned in Indiana being at a place
where you know a lot of my friends a lot
of my supporters even come from a
different place than I do
being pro-choice I just believe that
when a woman is in that situation and
when we're talking about some of those
situations covered by that law extremely
difficult painful often medically
serious situations where life or health
of the mother is at stake the
involvement of a male government
official like me is not healthy the
states have a right should states have a
right to ban abortion at 20 weeks that
sounds like a constitutional question
I'm not a legal scholar what I know is
that these questions ought to be
resolved by women in consultation with
their doctors not by the intervention of
male politicians putting politically
motivated restrictions on women's health
care well wait wait a minute what
happened to the gospel what what
happened to the creator Pete said that
God created him gay well we can talk
about that notion
he is right at least that God created
him that's true but did not did God not
also create the little babies who are
killed by abortion do they count for
nothing what about them
it's just it's very fascinating isn't it
that he's he's talking nonstop about the
gospel as soon as late term abortion
comes up he's got nothing to say about
the gospel apparently apparently you
know he thinks God has no opinion on on
that so he think good God has an opinion
on on immigration he God has an opinion
on Donald Trump
but apparently God has no opinion on on
abortion this is the problem that
liberals run into they feel that they
have to defend abortion all abortion
even late term abortion but that defense
undermines everything else they say
especially on matters of faith and
morals Pete's whole bit about
evangelical supporting Trump may have
had some kick to it and may have had
some real bite but then it's just blown
to smithereens because this guy when it
comes down to it will at a at a minimum
tolerate the killing of 32 week old
infants in the womb at a minimum he'll
tolerate it at a minimum he'll he'll put
up with it and say well I you know I
that's none of my business so abortion
continues to be in albatross for
Democrats as long as they support it
nothing else they say matters and some
issues are like that there are some
issues that you know just if you get
that wrong he it destroys everything
else you say I mean imagine if there was
a candidate out there defending slavery
or maybe not even defending it but just
saying well you know it's none of my
business if people have property rights
and I'm not going to get involved that
they don't need to hear my opinion
even even if there was even if there was
a candidate saying that taking a kind of
hand
off approach to the Kota to the question
well that would obviously destroy his
candidacy and we would all say rightly
so that listen there's you know it
doesn't matter what else this guy
doesn't matter how smart he is doesn't
matter about his resume it doesn't
matter about his leadership skills or
what I don't care what does what else
this guy's done if you get that question
wrong then you're not fit for leadership
and your opinion doesn't matter because
whatever else you say you're obviously
operating from a foundation that
includes treating human beings as
property as as as you know livestock and
so that's part of your fundamental
worldview then whatever grows from there
whatever springs forth from that is is
going to be deeply flawed to say the
least and so slavery is one of those
topics they're there rape is another one
of those subs if a candidate was out
there defending rape we would say again
that's a look that's a deal-breaker and
it should be well abortion is in that is
in that category Holocaust Allah cost
and denial it's another one if a
candidate is out there denying the
Holocaust or justifying it again doesn't
matter what else doesn't matter what
else they've done it makes notify your
own unmad or if you get that issue wrong
you're not fit and abortion again is one
of those this is the genocide of the
unborn if you can't get that right if
you can't figure that one out if either
you lack the intellectual clarity and
and moral insight to see what's wrong
with it or if you lack the courage to
speak out against it although you know
that it's wrong either way you're unfit
and so peat mayor Pete is unfit just
like all the other just like all the
other Democrats
okay let's take a look at this story
from the deli wire by Paul Bois in an
effort to differentiate himself from the
pack by moving us far to the left as he
can on the political spectrum senator
Cory Booker has now introduced a bill to
the Senate that would study the payment
of slavery reparations according to fox
news on monday the senator said the bill
will study whether or not slavery
reparations will help to alleviate past
racial injustice in the United States
Booker said the bill is a way of
addressing head-on the persistence of
racism white supremacy and implicit
racial bias in our country it will bring
together the best minds to study the
issue and propose solutions that will
finally begin to write the economic
scales of past harms and make sure we
are a country where all dignity and
humanity is affirmed Booker added that
slavery in this country fueled a
subsequent system of white supremacy
designed to keep black Americans from
competing economically and he goes on
from there talking about white supremacy
and and so and so forth well let me see
if I can help our friend
Spartacus out here can we alleviate in
justices from a hundred hundred and
fifty years ago well really I could just
stop the question right there can we
alleviate in justices from 150 years ago
no we can't there's nothing we can do
about them it's 150 years in the past
it's it's over we can't do anything to
write that ship anymore it's it's it's
it happened it's over now right there's
there's nothing we can do to go back and
make that okay slavery was a it was an
outrageous injustice it will always be
that way in the past and we can't go
back and change it if we could I wish we
could but we can't but especially can we
alleviate injustice is from 150 years
ago by taking money from people who had
nothing to do with it and giving it to
people who never suffered the injustice
in question no we cannot just as I
cannot alleviate the injustice of my
grandfather getting carjacked in 1962 by
slashing my neighbor's tires that's
going to do nothing for my grandfather
whose car was taken and and that's all
there is to it and who is who is dead
now anyway I don't know if my
grandfather was actually carjacked this
is just an example but it's not gonna do
anything for my grandfather who's not
even alive anymore and the person that I
am punishing for this injustice had
nothing to do with it so I'm teaching
him a lesson that didn't need to be
taught as far as I know he's never my
neighbors never carjacked anyone even if
I discovered that my neighbor is a
descendant of the guy who did the
carjacking even then the slashing of the
tires would just be another injustice
added on top of it we would be adding
injustice to injustice and that solves
nothing maybe you've noticed this about
leftist policies hopefully you have that
they leftist are always seeking to cure
injustice by creating more injustice
have you noticed that so you cure the
injustice has suffered by immigrants by
allowing them to break our laws and
undermine our national sovereignty which
is just creates more injustice you cure
the injustice suffered by a raped woman
by killing her baby who had nothing to
do with it you cure the injustice
suffered by the poor by stealing from
the rich you cure the the supposed
injustice is suffered by gay people by
taking First Amendment rights from
Christians you cure the injustice is of
racial discrimination by discriminating
against white people in the university
system and elsewhere with affirmative
action and and now you cure the
injustice of slavery by stealing from
people who never owned slaves so
everything is a zero-sum game with these
people everything is everything is
that's how everything works and I think
more maybe it's more so that everything
is a kind of a competition and this is
one of the fundamental flaws with the
less whole idea of human rights their
human rights
our version of human rights there claims
the human rights are always zero-sum
like in order for this group to have
rights we have to take rights away from
this other group it always works that
way with the left but the way that you
know that something is a real human
right is that it doesn't work that way
if something is a real human right then
you can grant it to a group of people
without taking anything from any other
group of people or without or I should
say you can if it's a real human right
you can grant it to a group of people
without depriving any other group of
their human rights now
if you want to grant human rights to
slaves then you are in a sense taking
something from slave owners that they
never had a right to in the first place
so you're not depriving them of human
rights but in in granting rights to
slaves
the slaves had rights but you're not
taking rights away from anybody else
because they never had a right to that
to begin with they never had a right to
own another person to begin with and
that's the way that works in of
religious liberty freedom of speech if
you if you give someone the right to go
out and speak their mind live their
beliefs that doesn't take anything away
from anyone else it may mean that other
people have to be inconvenienced or by
by listening to ideas they don't like
them they might even have to be offended
by listening to ideas they don't like
but they never had any right to not be
offended in the first place but with the
left no it's it's a competition so with
them it's well if you want to give
rights to two women that means that you
have to take the right to life from the
unborn but that's how you know that what
we're talking about with women here that
will it's not it's not a right at all
women have human rights they do not have
the right to kill anybody
any more than men do so that's how you
know all of these competing claims to
human rights it gets very confusing well
you ever find a situation where you've
got two competing claims and if one with
one group gets their rights the other
group gets has rights deprived of them
that's how you know that something is
wrong here that's how you know that that
we're not actually talking about rights
anymore we're talking about entitlements
and privileges and so on all right
before we get to emails I had something
else I wanted to mention very important
topic extremely crucial I have been
traveling a lot this month as I
mentioned a lot over the past like four
years really and so I've been in very
many airports and I have noticed this is
anecdotal of course but I have noticed
that there's been a huge uptick in the
number of parents who have their
toddlers on leashes this is something I
noticed especially in the last like
couple of weeks it seems every airport
now that I go to there are at least a
few parents walking their toddlers
around leashed now often the leash is
connected to the child's backpack but
Alicia is a leash I mean let's be honest
now I want to say this I was thinking
about it and I have long been anti leash
I have long been one of those people who
looks at the leash wielding parents and
shakes my head and says myself oh that's
awful oh that's that's how terrible how
do humanizing for that poor child but I
have three kids 5 and under now and I've
been in crowded places like airports
with all of these kids at once I have
had those moments where one of them runs
off and for about 12 seconds you you're
panicked and you think the tragedy is
truck and I will say that I it okay I
get the leash thing I didn't I didn't
used to get it but I get it now
now I don't use leashes because I can't
bear the looks that I would get from
people like myself so that's the only
reason I don't use them and I suspect
that's that's actually the reason why
most parents don't use them it's not
that you really have anything against it
it's just that you can't deal you know
how you always looked at those kinds of
parents and you don't want to get those
same looks and that's why you don't do
it but I do get it it's it's practical
it makes sense and I mean if you've
never at least considered the option of
using a leash then that tells me that
you've never been in charge of keeping
track of multiple young children at one
time in a busy place because if you have
then at the very least you've thought
about it you at the very least had a
moment where you thought okay yeah I I
see it now there are a lot of things
that parents do that non parents will
judge rather harshly and that's that's
why parents can get defensive sometimes
because when they get these judgments
from people who aren't even parents it
can be a little a little annoying or
even some you know I've noticed also
that as as parents especially of young
kids or if you're a parent of children
that you still have to look after you're
gonna get judged by non parents and also
sometimes older parents who have kids
that have long since grown and moved out
of the house who it seems like have
forgotten what it was like to actually
have young kids or maybe they don't
understand some of the challenges that
come with raising kids in the modern
world but I overtime and I think this is
a process that a lot of parents go
through I become much more tolerant and
understanding
I'm not tolerant and understanding in
many aspects of life but in this aspect
I am increasingly so when it comes to
parenting
another example is I used to hate the
idea of of TVs and cars I used to think
that you know we have TVs everywhere do
you really need a freakin TV in your car
for your kids to watch I used to be you
know I'd be hot behind someone traffic
and I would see through their car the
you know the screen on and some Disney
movie playing and the kids you know the
kids are in there watching the movie and
I used to think is that really necessary
I mean do you really need the TV there
but then I actually experienced driving
eight or ten or eleven hours in a car
with three kids five
and I experience that enclosed
up-close-and-personal whining and
talking and constant question asking and
are we there yet
and I'm hungry and I'm bored and bla bla
bla and and so yeah I I get why you turn
a movie home for them now why not it's a
tool that you have available to you it
makes everything easier it's not hurting
anyone so why not do it I think here's
what happens everyone has these grand
ideas about what kind of parent they're
gonna be what sort of what sort of rules
and policies they'll have in place once
they have kids and then they have kids
and and pretty quickly they realize that
a lot of those ideas are silly and
pointless and they're not worth the
trouble you had all these notions about
oh when I'm a parent I'm not going to do
that I'm not gonna do this there's gonna
be none of that and and then you become
a parent you're like yeah you know it
doesn't really matter yeah so now you
don't hopefully a band abandon all of
your priorities and principles you know
hopefully but you kind of boil them down
to the essentials that's what ends up
happening you figure out which lines you
feel you and your spouse feel cannot be
crossed and then you compromise on the
rest of it and that's fine like for me I
one of the things that was always
important to me and to my wife is I
don't like the idea of young kids
playing video games so I said we're not
gonna get video games for our kids at
this age or probably for a while longer
no matter if all their friends have them
which at this point all my son's friends
do have video games but that's not
something I want for our family so and
we've stuck to that and we're not gonna
do that it's important to us it's not
important to everybody some parents it's
not important to them they don't see it
as a big deal and that's fine I'm not
judging them it's whatever they want to
do some parents feel strongly about
dietary things like like soda you know
they won't let their kid go anywhere
near soda well we let our kids have a
soda on occasion we let them eat junk
food on occasion it's I don't really
care that much it's not a big deal I
don't see it as a big deal some parents
do whatever that's fine you figure out
what your lines are and then you
them and and and their duet there have
to be some lines that are just there and
that you don't cross you've got to have
some of those you can't just erase all
of them because then you're gonna you
know then you're going up with spoiled
bratty kids who get whatever they want
so you obviously can't do that
but there are going to be a lot of lines
that you drew before you actually had
kids and you didn't know what it was
like and you didn't you didn't know what
you were doing and then pretty quickly
you see those as superfluous and and so
you make practical decisions and
compromise and that's okay because
parenting is hard enough and you don't
need to create more challenges for
yourself you don't need to make it
harder than it actually already is one
big thing about parenting is guilt you
always feel guilty you always feel like
you're not doing a good enough job like
everyone else is everyone else is
squared away with their parenting but
you're not but that's not true because
nobody has it figured out see that's the
secret you learn after a while is it
when it comes to parenting no one knows
what the hell they're doing we're all
just we're all just figuring out as we
go along nobody knows I mean these these
kids are I mean they're they're human
beings they've got their own mind like
they've got their own identity they're
they have free will they can I mean you
could only control them so much and so
we're all kind of fumbling around in the
dark and figuring it out and and and
that's alright and so if you have to use
a leash then you use a leash that's my
point all right so that was about what
27 minutes on child leashes good good
stuff good content all right let's go to
emails Matt wall show at gmail.com Matt
wall show at gmail.com
let's see here so it says this is from
Karl says hey Matt I've listened to to
Ben Shapiro for years and I've heard you
on and off I recently started listening
to you regularly I appreciate that you
speak off it on Christianity that you
dive deep into subjects you ask hard
questions and don't claim to have all
the answers I've been a Christian for
almost 12 years now and I found that
some of the nastiest encounters people /
people I have dealt with are Christians
I've been through to church collapses
that ended with people not talking
calling each other demonic friendships
ending etc you receive a lot of angry
mail from fellow Christians why do you
think Christians behave this way on such
a frequent basis keep up the good work
you got another new fan Carl hi Carl
good question I think that there's
there's a lot in Christianity about
being hated by the world being set apart
from the world resisting the world and
so on and and all of that is true and
important but if a Christian doesn't
have the right perspective on those
injunctions if they don't have the right
heart about them they may start to think
that the world is literally everyone
except themselves that it's just them as
the sole right person the sole holy good
person and everybody else is wrong and
therefore deserving of their contempt
and scorn and ridicule and so on and
that's a real temptation I think that
can spring from the true words and
warnings in scripture about the world so
I think that has something to do with it
you know of course I mean the easy
answer is Christians or people they're
not perfect and they have all the same
flaws and foibles as other people and
that's true too but there there is as I
said there is something there are things
about Christianity that if you don't
look at them the right way and approach
them the right way can encourage you to
act the way that that you're talking
about so that's something we all have to
look out for this is from Joseph says hi
Matt a man from a fan for panels a fan
from Croatia here some time ago I asked
a question regarding penal labor the
question was basically about morality of
the penal labor is it moral and fair for
an inmate to be required to do a job in
some kind of prison factory and maybe in
which cases it is or isn't haven't
gotten the answer so I thought I might
try again love your work
god bless thanks Joseph sorry sorry that
I missed your email when he first sent
it I I think it's it's not only moral
and
fair to have inmates work but probably
more moral and and fair than the system
that we have here in the u.s. anyway
where most inmates just sit around in
their cells all day doing nothing
the idea behind putting them to work is
not just cheap labor but actually giving
the inmates something to do a way to
contribute and that has a restorative
effect I think hard work is almost
spiritual in that way it helps to
cleanse you refocus you so I think it's
it's it helps towards the rehabilitation
effort just being locked in a cage all
day like an animal I think that's way
less humane so yeah the idea of penal
labor I think it's perfectly humane and
and a good idea there is a hazard though
if you look throughout history where you
don't want to have penal labor because
of the cheap labor
if cheap labor becomes the point then
all of a sudden it's less penal labor
and more like slavery and there have
been many examples of that in history
think about the Soviets for instance
we're cheap labor was so much the point
of the gulag system that people would be
sent to prison on bogus charges just so
that they could be enlisted to build
railroads or whatever else so obviously
you don't want that that's a risk but if
you if you have a if you could have a
system that is just and fair and and
where the people who are you know and
you have a one of the problems in Soviet
Union is that you didn't have a real
court system to actually find out if
people were guilty or not you had people
that eventually would we're forced to
admit their guilt through torture and so
on so if you don't have that if you have
a real court system then I think it
could be a good thing to have this is
from John says dear Matt this is going
to be a long email and I apologize today
my dad came up to me saying he wants to
take a job in two to three years that
would move us from Chicago to Utah that
sounds great as a conservative on paper
but my parents are divorced and I've
been anxiously waiting for the
opportunity to be with my mom more as I
don't see her
as often I would be able to finish my
high school career and all but I would
be shaken up a little going out due to
this it's always been a dream of mine to
also live in Chicago like my parents but
it's grown a little hard due to the
blueness of the state
I know Utah's a fairly religious state -
which would be a plus but I just don't
know how it would see my mom or what
career I'd go into I want to go into
broadcast communications if you could
help me out even a little that'd be
greatly appreciated well it sounds like
a tough situation John
so I'm sorry you're going through that
but listen here's the good news
eventually you'll be 18 right and you'll
be 18 and you'll be out of high school
and then you can live wherever you want
so you know go with the program now if
your dad's the main one who's in charge
of you then you go with him but it's
only temporary and if ultimately you
decide that you want to live in Chicago
you could always move back to Chicago
you can move wherever you want that's
the nothing is permanent out of your age
or really at any age you can always
change it if you want and that's that's
something maybe you've heard me
preaching this before that's something
that I think young people who you know
are adults and emancipated in that way
but that's something that I think young
people forget I mean you can once you're
18 you can go live wherever you want and
the whole world is open to you
and so I would say I mean take advantage
of that thanks for the email this is
from Paul says rank these top 90s TV
shows NYPD Blue Ally McBeal Frasier
Seinfeld friends well I hate to say it
Paul but I and I'm gonna lose a lot of
cred as a 90's kid here but I've only
seen one of those shows Seinfeld I've
never seen a single episode of any of
that I've never seen a single episode of
friends ever I have I have seen every
Seinfeld episode probably multiple times
so you know I would have to just put
Seinfeld at the top and by default I
hate to say look when in the 90s I was
yeah I was born in 86 so most of the 90s
for me was was Nickelodeon so you know
he
you really you got to give me
Nickelodeon shows to rank and then I
could do that for you this is from
Travis says hi Matt I enjoyed your
review of the 90s bands yesterday can
you please rank these 90 comedy movies
keep up the good work Matt loved the
show
alright the movies are clerks Dumb and
Dumber Tommy Boy
office space The Big Lebowski okay well
this is good I have seen these alright I
can do this if this is a tough one
it's actually really tough I was
thinking about this I spent hours
thinking about this when I saw this
email all right so I'll go five to one
one being best obviously number five
will be clerks
I know clerks is a quintessential 90s
movie it doesn't really hold up I don't
know if you've tried to watch clerks
recently it's it's pretty unwatchable
now so I'll put that at number five
number four would be Tommy boy look I
love cliffs Chris Farley everybody does
but and it's a funny movie it's just
it's not it it's funny just because
Chris Farley's being Chris Farley it's
not it's not an especially clever movie
aside from that number three would I
guess I put the Big Lebowski I mean The
Big Lebowski is a great cult movie
iconic movie but I don't even know if
I'd call it a comedy I mean it is a
comedy but it's not it's not like a
laugh out loud funny all the way through
it's just it's kind of it kind of defies
all genres so for this these purposes I
put it number three number two I would
put office space this was a close one
the office space is a classic and that's
that's one you can watch that you can
watch that whenever that's on TV you
just watch it you'll always laugh I
would put number one Dumb and Dumber I
just think it it of course is an
incredibly stupid movie it's called dumb
and dumber but the comedy holds up I've
probably seen Dumb and Dumber 30 times
and or more and I still think it's funny
office space and dumber dumber you can
really switch those around because they
both are funny every time you watch them
but I would put dumb and dumber number
one all right let's do one more okay
we'll do a we'll do a good theological
one here this is from Victor says hi
Matt my name is Victor I was posed an
interesting question when talking with a
co-worker today about intelligent design
and he being an atheist asked me
where did God come from who made God he
stated that he has never heard a good
answer for this therefore cannot believe
in God listening to your podcast about
addressing issues of a scientific or
factual basis with non-believers what's
your thought on this thanks in advance
okay Victor well your friends question
is not stupid it's not a stupid question
sometimes Christians can treat this
objection like it like it is stupid but
it's perfectly legitimate if if we are
insisting that God made the universe
because everything has to have a
beginning and nothing can begin without
a cause then it is absolutely legitimate
and logical for someone to say well what
about God and if you don't because that
is the argument that's one of the most
compelling arguments for God for the
existence of God is that is that well
everything has to have a beginning the
universe began thing cannot make itself
begin because in order for a thing to do
anything it has to first exist so that's
why a thing cannot will itself into
existence that's a logical contradiction
has to have beginning so God so you need
some sort of creative force that's an
argument for God but if you're gonna say
something like everything has to have a
beginning and and you also believe that
God exists then he must be included in
everything he's part of that isn't he
especially if you believe that God is
omnipresent so then he's really part of
everything he is you know in everything
well you want to be careful with that
you'll want to sound like you're a
pantheist but you get the point so
that's that's a logical response and too
often I hear theists respond to that by
saying come on but yeah obviously God's
an exception you don't want to sound
like your special pleading so how do we
respond to that well we respond to it
this way God by the Christian
understanding by the you know really the
monotheistic
understanding the Abrahamic religion
understanding really God is the is the
ground of all being right he is he is he
is not seen we don't think of God the
way the pagans do or did maybe still do
if there are pagans out there we don't
see God despite how the atheists portray
our belief we don't see God as a man in
the clouds holding a you know staff with
a white beard sitting on a throne kind
of thing such a that kind of God would
absolutely need a beginning he would
need his own God to have created him but
that's not how we see God that's not
this sort of sophisticated idea of God
in Christianity we see God as the as the
the ground of all being the foundation
upon which all of reality exists he is a
non-contingent being in that all things
that exist that we see around us are all
contingent on other things for their
existence they they continued that they
needed something else to have created
them to have spawned them they rely on
something else for their existence so
all things are contingent things but God
is not and it seems a logical conclusion
that we cannot possibly live in a
universe filled only with contingent
things if everything is contingent if
everything is dependent on something
else for its existence then eventually
you're gonna get to the end of that
chain and then what what's at the end of
it what's there you're gonna get to that
sort of last link on the chain of a
contingent thing but then if it's
contingent then what's what is it a
contingent upon your at the end of the
chain right so that means that at bottom
you have to get to something that just
is it just is it just it it just exists
it is existence and that thing that
is must have the ability to create what
else there is that must be the
non-contingent contingency and that
being must be timeless because time has
a beginning and is therefore contingent
it must be spaceless because space has a
beginning and so and it must be creative
because it created all these other
things so it must be a timeless
spaceless creative non-contingent being
and that's what we mean by God hope that
made sense but that's basically how you
respond to that objection and and I
would just stress again you know respond
to it in a thoughtful way not not a
dismissive way because it's a this idea
of non contingent beings and all these
guys I mean it's not like this is these
are difficult concepts and so if someone
has never encountered them or doesn't
understand them then it doesn't make
them stupid doesn't make their questions
stupid it just means that you know it's
something that needs to be explained so
alright thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening hopefully I'll see
you out of barrel up baler tonight if
you're if you're in town and if not I
will talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed hey everybody its Andrew Clavin
host of the Andrew Clavin show Trump
says there's an emergency at the border
and the media Democrat complex spends
hour after hour saying he's wrong and if
he's not wrong he's to blame and if he's
not to blame
look there's a crying baby we'll talk
about it on the Andrew Clavin show
I'm Andrew Clavin